[Musique]
pardon non si vous avez dit quoi qu'ils
arrêtent trop de peau dispense a fait
ses preuves en sont agréables les
chiffres sont encourageants
ces derniers jours plusieurs indicateurs
sont à la baisse le nombre de cas
positifs sur sept jours a baissé de 4%
le nombre de personnes hospitalisées de
2% et le nombre de morts quotidiens a
chuté de 6%
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
donner
c'est tous
c'est quoi ta difficulté à ce moment de
ta vie si tu peux nous raconter des
précieux et je suis triste et ça me
donne envie de mourir pour emma tout a
commencé au moment du premier
confinement j'ai simplement comparer la
proportion de personnes âgées de plus de
80 ans qui décès des ducs ovide 19 à la
propension de ces personnes de plus de
80 ans qu'une année disons normal en
l'occurrence en 2019 était décédé donc
sur l'ensemble de l'année décidément il
ya mes pompes qui sont complètement à
gauche et moi qui suis je trop difficile
mais j'essaie de me rapprocher de mes
chaussures de là je sais un petit peu à
côté d'eux mais pour hbo ces deux
proportion enfants sont identiques
autrement dit l'idée que les personnes
âgées sont plus atteinte est une idée
juste mais ils ne sont pas plus atteinte
qu'en période normale c'était exactement
la même chose en france qu'en période
normale pour elle le confinement
signifient et vacances alors elle n'a
pas compris quand elle a vu ses parents
de travailler tous les jours depuis la
maison dès qu'on m'a demandé si je
voulais retourner à l'école j'ai tout de
suite dit oui mais quand il m'a appuyé
retourner son état ne s'est pas
améliorée
h comment ça triste et puis roulez trop
passer du temps avec les autres puis à
j'ai commencé à vouloir mourir et je
commence à me faire du mal
dans ce
[Musique]
t'as pas là
nous restons donc une année de plus à
paris une année que nous rendrons le
plus riche possible
[Musique]
janica français dans le plus beau payons
pour l'anniversaire de leur pays
les émirats arabes unis ont vu les
choses en grand ils se sont offert un
voyage vers mars
en plaçant mardi sur orbite une sonde
nommé espoir au peuple des émirats aux
nations arabes et musulmanes
nous annonçons de rentrée réussie en
orbite autour de mars
dieu soit loué quelques et vous n'aimez
pas l'unité de la france voit la beauté
qui n'aimait pas les femmes
northug ne vous dérange pas que les
femmes soient voilées que les femmes
portent des burkinis en hachant lieu le
sujet ça ne vous dérange pas qu'on a
changé de sujet des horaires décalés
vous anciens c'est là par les ans les
perdre et qu'on dise est méchante et
agressif
regardez le vilain visage crispé contre
moi moi je suis pour l'égalité halde et
oui pas moi peut-être parce que vous
êtes juste j'ai paniqué pour m'occuper
du genre un projet qui voit très loin il
s'appelle mars 2000 sont 17 ans dans un
siècle
l'objectif c'est de simuler la vie sur
mars et surtout de développer la
technologie nécessaire pour coloniser la
planète dans un prototype qui est bâti
ici sur terre dubaï investi des sommes
colossales plus de 120 millions d'euros
moi j'ai le droit aussi de dire que je
ne suis pas d'accord pour me retrouver
au même endroit quelqu'un qui me tarde
d'y faire mais bon quand on l'a invité
c'était la seule condition tournoi où la
nier ou non on colle des balles moi vous
être été très chaud plusieurs fois et
j'ai rien dit j'ai pas dit que je
partais du plateau monsieur mélenchon
est donc l inverse est vrai aussi c'est
donc arrêtez de vous plaindre tout le
monde est clair c'est pas agréable mais
vous faites la même chose avec le
nouveau producteur crème et vous
répondez pas ne dites pas les médias et
bfm tv
il ya les médias je suis parce que c'est
moins immédiat c'est tout un chacun qui
mange mil 2015 mouvement 30 chaînes je
sais pas ce que c'est pour moi je peux
vous parler de ce qui se passe sur cette
chaîne et de ce qui se passe dans mes
émissions
on peut en parler très calmement et très
librement trouvez-vous la drogue
aujourd'hui
vous êtes là sur ce plateau et je vous
laisse parler mais surtout ça non le
joueur est invité donc la parole alors
avant de lancer le sujet je suis obligé
de vous poser une question est ce que
quelqu'un s'oppose à ma présence
vous paraît parfois qu'est ce que vous
répondez à jean luc mélenchon qu'elle
n'a pas voulu de vous sur la première
partie de vacances ton post je le salue
pour son sens de la démocratie et du
courage
s'il n'a pas le courage d'affronter
naulleau et qu'il devient président est
ce qu'il aura le courage de l'affronter
poutine elle est super forte
enfin elle est super forte mais elle est
super malhonnête et elle fait tout le
temps la victime pour essayer de se
faire passer pour la gentille mais non
en fait c'est pas parce que tu es une
victime que t'es pas vie s'use en fait
levis on le voit tu l'as levis tournevis
la boîte à outils l'ingénieur est
l'atout elle et je dois dire que entre
dans le passage entre les deux émissions
il a une attitude à mon à mon endroit un
peu agressive il décèle un petit peu je
les coulisses un nom la sécheresse au
moment du passage d'antenne il a eu une
attitude un peu un peu agressive même
physiquement j'ai pas bien compris oui
même notre ami notre ami bernard laporte
s'est inquiété est revenu à la crème
quand je me coiffe en général je finis
avec un peu de laque ans près juste pour
que tout reste en place mais la dernière
fois j'avais plus de lacs
donc j'ai utilisé sarthe de la colle en
spray gorilla cru très très très
mauvaise idée
regardez la publicité autour de
justement celle qu'elle a utilisé donc
là s'appelle borias comme vous venez de
le voir et c'est pour montrer qu en fait
même un gorille avec la force qui est là
n'arrivent pas à décoller les choses
parce que ce spray est vraiment
extrêmement efficace je me suis lavé les
cheveux 15 fois et ils ne bougent pas
rien surtout si vous tombez en panne de
lacq en soirée n'utilisez jamais jamais
de la colle sauf si vous voulez me
ressemble et pour toujours
le guide vient d'être publié destination
des athlètes 33 pages de règles
sanitaires très strictes à appliquer
dans le village olympique masque
obligatoire toute la journée
interdiction de se saluer un test tous
les quatre jours pour tout le monde mais
les organisateurs maintiennent leur
intention distille de distribuer 150000
préservatifs aux athlètes
le message paradoxal l'ordi en fait pas
question de se serrer la main en
revanche on peut imaginer des galipettes
masqué
et couverts j'ai toujours dit que le
climat serait beaucoup plus sain aux
états unis si on pouvait accepter que la
sexualité humaine est très importante
humer un des aspects les plus importants
de la vie il m'arrivait d'être au
téléphone avec son ex parce que c'est
toujours mon meilleur ami est en fin de
discussion il arrivait que je lui
demande quelques conseils sur ce qui lui
plaisait au lit ou bien et mes cessé
pour autant servir de l'expérience des
autres aussi que nous sommes censés en
profiter et nous en avoir honte
beaucoup de progrès peuvent être
accomplies n'y sommes pas encore on y
est presque
même si ça ne va pas aussi vite que je
le veux